We just developed a slow cooker for Beautiful,
which is the kitchen line that I created and designed
with all of the people that I work with,
and a slow cooker is something
that I'm really passionate about because there are recipes
that can entail a whole lot of business
before going in the slow cooker,
or there are some where you can literally throw it in,
turn it on, and come back to a gorgeous meal.
So, I'm gonna demonstrate one of those
and Pilar is gonna demonstrate
the dessert version.
Ooh!
This is so revelatory.
I never think sweet when I see slow cooker,
I always think savory.
Yeah.
So, you are blowing my mind, and also showing, again,
the versatility of this gorgeous slow cooker.
Now, I'm gonna demonstrate a Slow Cooked Pork Carnitas.
This is a recipe near and dear to my heart.
Okay, now here's what I'm gonna show you how to do.
First of all, you're gonna put your meat
directly in the slow cooker.
So, I am using a pork shoulder.
I have cumin
and oregano in here,
and cumin is truly one of my favorite spices.
It's pretty much in most things that I'm obsessed with.
I think it's all over our recipes
in the book as well. (chuckles)
So, you're gonna take that spice
and work it through the meat just to flavor it,
and then you're literally going to throw it
in your slow cooker.
Rogue piece, watch out.
(Pilar laughing)
Watch out for those little rogue pieces,
and if there's any that you missed,
just right in the slow cooker,
grab it, salt it.
I love that.
Continue to stir.
Now part of the seasoning is also the salsa.
This is something I created because I love to tomatillos,
and usually when you get tacos,
it's a red or a pico de gallo,
and I love
a nice, green Verde salsa, so this is so simple.
It is literally garlic,
onions, tomatillo,
cilantro,
jalapeños,
and the secret ingredient
is a little bit of beer.
Ooh!
It just gives it that extra flavor profile
that really, really does it for me.
Literally, that is it.
Now you can cook it low and slow
for six to eight hours,
or you can kick up the heat a tiny bit
and actually, like on a medium or high,
and that reduces your cooking time down
to four to six hours,
and come back to a gorgeous meal with incredible texture.
(audience applauding)
Do we get to taste? (laughs)
Now, one of the things
that's so important
is to get that restaurant-style quality.
You've gotta get that fork out and shred it.
So, don't be scared if there are still some chunks in place.
That's totally natural and normal.
You can get two forks actually
and go at the same time in sort of that formation,
and then you can put your little fixings
on the side.
It smells incredible.
And I notice we have
a little pickled onion here.
Yes.
That really works well with this recipe,
also a little cream, I know, I'm dying.
Cheers, I love you.
Cheers.
I love you.
(audience applauding loudly)
And it's all due to some seasoning and some slow cooking.
Pilar, your turn.
(audience applauding)
I'm like, wait, I'm busy eating, hold on.
I kind of threw it to you
so I could keep eating.
Oh, I'm sorry.
(upbeat music)